meine Damen meine Herren ich darf Sie
herzlich begrüßen zur Pressekonferenz im
Anschluss an die Zusammenkunft des
Bundeskanzlers mit den
regierungschefinnen und Regierungschefs
der Länder wir beginnen wie üblich mit
dem Bundeskanzler den ich hier herzlich
begrüßen will nicht minder herzlich die
Regierende Bürgermeisterin von Berlin
und natürlich den Ministerpräsident von
Nordrhein-Westfalen herr Scholz die
fangen an
meine Damen und Herren noch ist das Jahr
22 nicht ganz alt geworden und deshalb
möchte ich auch an dieser Stelle noch
einmal die besten Wünsche für das neue
Jahr an sie alle übermitteln
und gleichzeitig ist mir wichtig hier
Dank auszusprechen viele haben
mitgeholfen dass wir über die Zeit
gekommen sind wir haben Regeln
festgesetzt aber es haben sich eben auch
sehr viele in diese Regeln gehalten wer
das genau vergleicht wird feststellen
dass Deutschland sicher in Europa zu den
Ländern zählt die mit die präzisesten
und weitreichendsten
kontaktbeschränkungsregeln festgelegt
haben aber auch mit guten Konsequenzen
wenn wir das infektions-geschehen
betrachten wir können das Sehen in den
Krankenhäusern wir haben auch
entsprechende Nachrichten aus vielen
vielen anderen Konsequenzen
desinfektionsgeschehens in den letzten
Tagen sehen können und trotzdem obwohl
die Lage durch all die Maßnahmen die wir
ergriffen haben besser ist als man
befürchten musste wissen wir dass die
neue
unicronvariante dazu führen wird dass
die Infektionen zunehmen werden und wir
werden in den nächsten Tagen und Wochen
auch größere Zahlen sehen als wir sie
heute auch schon erkennen können das
wissend ist es notwendig dass wir uns
darauf vorbereiten dass die
Infektionszahlen steigen werden und dass
wir alle notwendigen Maßnahmen ergreifen
genau darüber haben wir uns unterhalten
und verständigt heute in dieser
Konferenz aber was mir wichtig ist auch
die ganze Zeit über schon zwischen den
Tagen und Anfang des Jahres es hat
intensive Beratung gegeben
mit Hilfe des RKI mit Hilfe unseres
Expertengremiums zusammen mit dem
Gesundheitsminister Beratung der
Gesundheitsminister und
Gesundheitsministerin es hat intensive
Beratung geben der Chefs der senats- und
Staatskanzleien der Länder mit dem
Kanzleramtsminister und auch viele
andere haben sich die ganze Zeit
beteiligt daran dass wir hier eine gute
vorbereitete Entscheidung haben
klar ist und wir kommen wird uns noch
lange beschäftigen und deshalb kann man
auch nicht eine Entwarnung für unser
Gesundheitssystem aussprechen wir werden
das muss mit aller Klarheit und
Deutlichkeit gesagt haben werden höhere
Infektionen sehen und es wird auch viele
neue Patienten in den Krankenhäusern
geben deshalb müssen wir uns auf diese
Situation vorbereiten und tun das auch
wir wissen alle was hilft neben den
kontaktbeschränkungen über die es noch
zu reden gilt geht es darum dass wir das
Impfen und Boostern weiter vorantreiben
der beste Schutz vor Omicron ist eine
booster-impfung und deshalb ist es gut
dass wir unser Ziel dass wir zuletzt
gesetzt hatten bis Weihnachten 30
Millionen
Impfungen zu erreichen auch tatsächlich
erreicht haben und es ist genauso gut
dass wir ihr geizig am nächsten Ziel
arbeiten nämlich bis zum Ende dieses
Monats die nächsten 30 Millionen
boosterimpfung zu organisieren
alle Impfstoffe die wir heute verfügbar
haben helfen und sind gut das gilt
insbesondere für den Impfstoff von
moderner und den von biontech beide sind
in gleicher Weise geeignet zu schützen
und wir haben sehr viele davon zur
Verfügung insbesondere was moderner
betrifft und deshalb bitte ich alle dass
sie diesen Impfstoff nebenbänder zur
Verfügung steht und sich entsprechend
impfen lassen es hilft gegen die
Infektionen durch die Omegon Variante
und das omicronvirus und das ist glaube
ich für uns alle ganz ganz wichtig eine
frische Impfung bietet unverändert den
besten Schutz und das gilt auch für
diejenigen die bisher noch gar nicht
geimpft sind auch die erste und
Zweitimpfung ist ausgesprochen hilfreich
wer sich schon einmal hat impfen lassen
ist besser vor den gesundheitlichen
Folgen geschützt selbst wenn da noch
nicht den ganzen Schutz hat damit der
dritten Auffrischungsimpfung dann
verbunden ist
was auch hilft das wissen wir
mittlerweile ist das Tragen von Masken
von medizinischen Masken von ffp2-masken
und das empfehlen wir auch an vielen
Stellen die Nutzung dieser Masken
schreiben Sie auch in vielen Bereichen
unverändert fort es hilft
ich habe schon darüber gesprochen dass
wir in Deutschland eine relativ
bessere Entwicklung bisher haben als in
vielen Nachbarländern auch deshalb weil
wir so weitreichende
kontaktbeschränkungen bisher festgelegt
haben und deshalb wird das auch für die
Zukunft weiter notwendig sein also gibt
es darum viele persönliche Kontakte zu
reduzieren für private Kontakte ist eine
Beschränkung auf zehn Personen
unverändert gültig und für ungeimpfte
gilt unverändert ein der eigene Haushalt
kann sich mit maximal zwei weiteren
Personen treffen wir haben unverändert
die strenge Regelung von 3G im
öffentlichen Verkehr und das gilt auch
für Theater und Kinos und Kulturbereich
2G manchmal auch zwei gibt plus
wir wissen dass Omikron viel
ansteckender ist als die bisherigen
Virusvarianten die wir im Rahmen der
corona-pandemie kennengelernt haben und
deshalb sind wir darüber eingekommen
dass wir etwas was in einigen Ländern in
Deutschland schon gilt jetzt
flächendeckend einführen wollen nämlich
das in Restaurants und Kneipen wo man ja
keine Masken tragen kann wenn man am
Platz sitzt und ist oder etwas trinkt
dann auch entsprechend klare Regelung
haben deshalb ist es so dass wir dort
vorschreiben wollen dass dort nur
diejenigen hingehen können die
vollständig geimpft sind oder ein Test
haben bzw zusätzlich
gewusst hat ist der kann auch dort diese
Möglichkeit nutzen ohne sich noch mehr
extra testen zum lassen das ist eine
strenge Regelung Zweige Plus oder
gepustert ins Restaurant gehen zu können
aber es ist eine notwendige die dazu
beiträgt dass wir besser vorankommen und
dass wir Infektionen besser
kontrollieren können als das jetzt der
Fall ist
weil wir uns auch darüber klar sind dass
es notwendig ist sich auf das
vorzubereiten was kommt haben wir uns
auch auseinandergesetzt mit den
Quarantäne und Isolierung Vorschriften
die im Zusammenhang mit Infektionen dann
eintreten
und deshalb ist klar dass wir es möglich
machen müssen mit einer Situation
umzugehen in der viele
infiziert werden könnten darum die erste
Regelung der gebustert ist muss als
Kontaktperson nicht mehr in Quarantäne
darauf haben wir uns verständigt in
enger Rücksprache mit allen Beteiligten
die dafür zuständig sind in Deutschland
alle anderen können nach zehn Tagen die
Quarantäne bzw die Isolation verlassen
wenn dann keine Symptome mehr da sind
und diese Frist kann verkürzt werden
wenn Betroffenen PCR-Test oder einen
anerkannten
Schnelltest haben auf sieben Tage
natürlich gilt für besonders vulnerable
Gruppen
wo viele zu schützen sind etwas anderes
im Krankenhäusern im Pflegeheim kann die
Quarantäne und Isolation
sicherheitshalber nach sieben Tagen aber
nur mit einem PCR-Test verkürzt werden
das sind strenge Regeln die aber
pragmatisch sind und die eine
Erleichterung bedeuten gegenüber den
heutigen Regelungen wir haben uns im
übrigen darum bemüht Sie möglichst
überschaubar zu machen so dass man sie
gut verstehen kann sie alle bekommen im
übrigen von uns noch dieses schöne
Schaubild erreicht und wir werden das
auch öffentlich zur Verfügung stellen
damit man das gut nachvollziehen kann
was dann in Zukunft überall in
Deutschland umgesetzt werden wird weil
es viele bewegt in den Schulen werden
Masken getragen in den Schulen wird oft
getestet und deshalb haben wir auch
leichtere Vorschriften für die
Schülerinnen und Schüler festgelegt und
dann entsprechend nach fünf Tagen wenn
ein Test vorliegt der Schulbetrieb
wieder aufgenommen also man wieder zur
Schule gehen kann
meine Damen und Herren das alles sind
weitreichende regeln wir werden dazu
beitragen dass wir uns besser durch
diese Situation bewegen können aber wir
müssen wissen dass alles geschieht in
einer Lage in der die Infektion zunehmen
werden deshalb ist es für uns auch
wichtig dass wir die Wirtschaftshilfen
verlängern die wir heute haben und noch
mal gerade für die Gastronomie
verbessern auch das ist mit den heutigen
Beschlüssen verbunden was ist mir zum
Schluss noch mal wichtig zu sagen dass
impfen ist wichtig wir brauchen weiteren
im Fortschritt es ist vorangekommen aber
nicht so schnell wie man sich das
wünschen muss die Impfquote in
Deutschland das unverändert nicht sehr
hoch und ich sage an dieser Stelle auch
und bin nicht der Markt dass ich der
Meinung bin dass es gut ist wenn am Ende
eine allgemeine Impfpflicht steht ich
habe das schon im letzten Jahr als meine
Position dargestellt der Bundestag wird
dazu über demnächst beraten und auch die
Länder alle 16 Regierungschefin und
Regierungschefs der Länder haben sich
dazu be dass sie für eine allgemeine
Impfpflicht sind dass es mit diesem
Beschluss ja auch verbunden ich fühle
mich da maximal unterstützen und das ist
glaube ich auch eine gute Grundlage für
die Beratung die jetzt im Deutschen
Bundestag anstehen
gleichzeitig müssen wir für das Boostern
werben ich bitte das alle mithelfen das
hohe Tempo dass wir insbesondere vor
Weihnachten hatten müssen wir bald
wieder erreichen und wenn uns das
gelingt dann haben wir eine Chance
besser mit der jetzigen Situation
umzugehen als wenn wir das nicht tun es
liegt also an uns wie schwierig die
Herausforderung wird die mit dieser
Gesundheitskrise verbunden ist die aus
einer weltweiten Virusinfektionen
entsteht wenn wir weiter konsequent
unsere kontaktbeschränkung durchsetzen
wenn wir weiter konsequent auf impfen
und Boostern setzen dann haben wir eine
gute Aussicht so gut wie möglich durch
diese Situation zu kommen und möglichst
viele Bürgerinnen und Bürger zu schützen
vielen Dank als nächstes der Vorsitzende
der
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
Nordrhein-Westfalens Ministerpräsident
Hendrik wüst ja vielen Dank erlauben Sie
mir zunächst ihnen allen zu Beginn die
sind neun Jahres alles Gute für dieses
Jahr zu wünschen vor allen Dingen
Gesundheit und dann passt es auch zum
Thema der heutigen Beratung die
omicron-mutation hat weltweit eine sehr
starke Dynamik im Infektionsgeschehen
ausgelöst die
Weltgesundheitsorganisation hat einen
neuen weltweiten Höchststand an
Neuinfektionen gemeldet bei unseren
europäischen Nachbarn steigende
Infektionszahlen und auch die
krankenhausaufnahmen dramatisch an auch
bei uns in Deutschland ist die sieben
Tages Inzidenz auf mehr als 300
gestiegen und die experten erwarten für
die nächsten Tage und Wochen einen
deutlichen Anstieg der Infektionszahlen
um Nikon verlangt deshalb von uns
Achtsamkeit Entschlossenheit und vor
allen Dingen vorausschauendes und
verlässliches handeln
die Impfung ist und bleibt ein zentrales
Mittel der pandemiebekämpfung seit der
Vorsitzende des expertenrates heute auch
noch mal deutlich bekräftigt die
Vorbereitung einer allgemeinen
Impfpflicht ist deshalb Teil einer
vorausschauenden pandemiepolitik Bund
und Länder haben deshalb er bereits im
Dezember am 21 Dezember gemeinsam gesagt
dass Omikron die Dringlichkeit einer
allgemeinen Impfpflicht
erhöht wir haben diesen Beschluss heute
noch einmal bekräftigt für den gern noch
mal vortragen das Auftreten der
unicronenvariante erhöht die
Dringlichkeit der für die mit dem
Beschluss vom 2 Dezember 21 für Februar
22 in den Blick genommenen Einführung
einer allgemeinen Impfpflicht die Länder
bitten den Bundestag und die
Bundesregierung die diesbezüglichen
Vorbereitung zügig voranzutreiben und
kurzfristig ein Zeitplan vorzulegen das
war der Beschluss den wir dann am 21
Dezember noch einmal gefasst und heute
bekräftigt haben auch der der
Bundeskanzler das im November in
Aussicht gestellt auch mit der
zeitlichen Perspektive Anfang
Februar ich habe das letztes mal schon
gesagt dieses Wort muss am Ende auch
gelten wir brauchen Tempo und auch für
Tempo und auch Führungen bei dieser
Frage ist darf nicht das Gefühl
entstehen dass bei dieser zentralen
Frage für die pandemiebekämpfung
taktiert wird Politik muss da auch
verlässlich sein die Länder gehen davon
aus dass bald ein Zeitplan für das
weitere Vorgehen zur Einführung einer
allgemeinen Impfpflicht vorliegen wird
die Quarantäne bleibt auch bei Omikron
ein wichtiges Werkzeug um die
Verbreitung der Infektionen zu verlangen
Samen gleichzeitig muss es ein
Unterschied machen ob sich Menschen
durch einen Booster besonders geschützt
haben oder nicht das ist auch ein
wichtiger Anreiz für die
booster-impfung Bund und Länder haben
auf dieser Basis gemeinsam ein
ausgewogenes quarantänekonzept
erarbeitet wichtig war für uns dabei
dass wir besonders verwundbar und auch
unser Gesundheitssystem insgesamt
schützen außerdem bereiten wir uns
darauf vor dass steigende
Infektionszahlen auch Auswirkungen haben
auf das Personal in der kritischen
Infrastruktur wir müssen unser Land auch
dann am Laufen halten wenn mehr Menschen
infiziert oder in Quarantäne sind dazu
werden Pandemiepläne angepasst
zu einer vorausschauenden
pandemiepolitik gehört auch auf künftige
Entwicklungen vorbereitet zu sein der
Expertenrat der Bundesregierung weist
ausdrücklich darauf hin dass wir in den
nächsten Wochen in der Lage sein müssen
schnell auf die dynamische Entwicklung
reagieren zu können aus Sicht der
Regierungschefs der unionsgeführten
Länder und Baden-Württembergs ist
deshalb erforderlich dass der Bundestag
die epidemische Lage feststellt denn die
Länder brauchen die Möglichkeit schnell
mit zusätzlichen Schutzmaßnahmen
reagieren zu können wenn die
Infektionszahlen wie in anderen
europäischen Ländern
explosionsartig ansteigen sollten lassen
Sie mich zum Schluss noch ein Wort zur
gesamtgesellschaftlichen Lage sagen wir
sehen auch im Westen immer mehr
sogenannte Spaziergänger von Querdenkern
corona-leugnern
Impfgegnern und wie immer sie sich
nennen
klar ist dass Demonstrationsrecht gilt
auch in der Pandemie aber die Bedrohung
und Einschüchterung von Amtsträgern von
Verantwortungsträgern oder gar Angriffe
auf sie tolerieren wir nicht Hass und
Drogen durch Corona Leubner und
Impfgegner schlagen mittlerweile vielen
Verantwortungsträgern auf allen Ebenen
entgegen danke deshalb ausdrücklich
allen Beschäftigten in Krankenhäusern
Kommunalverwaltungen und Behörden allen
unseren Polizistinnen und Polizisten
Ordnungskräften dass sie trotzdem ihre
Pflicht tun und sich nicht beirren
lassen wir stehen an ihrer Seite
dann als nächstes die Regierende
Bürgermeisterin von Berlin Franziska
Giffey ja meine Damen und Herren sehr
geehrter Herr Bundeskanzler sehr
geehrter Herr Kollege Wüste ich will
zunächst einmal sagen dass ich mich
wirklich herzlich bedanke für die sehr
gute Vorbereitung dieser
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz anhand der
Dauer oder besser der Kürze können Sie
ersehen dass es hier eine sehr sehr gute
Vorbereitung gab die uns ermöglicht hat
hier wirklich auch zügig zu einer
gemeinsamen Beschlussfassung zu kommen
und das ist natürlich auch der
stringenten Führung und der guten
Vorarbeit hier aus dem Bundeskanzleramt
zu verdanken ich finde wichtig dass wir
an jeder Stelle an der wir Maßnahmen
treffen nicht nur eine vorausschauende
pandemiepolitik machen wie Herr wüst das
geschildert hat sondern auch eine
maßvolle pandemie-politik die eben sich
an der Nachvollziehbarkeit an der
Verständlichkeit von Maßnahmen aber auch
an der Verhältnismäßigkeit von Maßnahmen
orientiert denn es ist ganz klar jeder
Einschränkung die wir zusätzlich treffen
muss abgewogen werden mit den
Einschränkungen der Freiheitsrechte die
unsere Bürgerinnen und Bürger haben und
das haben wir sehr verantwortungsvoll
gemacht es geht darum dass wir mit der
unicronvariante eine zusätzliche ja
Verstärkung der Situation der
Schwierigkeiten der absehbar hohen
Infektionszahlen haben auf die wir
reagieren müssen und deshalb ist es auch
vertretbar dass wir heute zu weiteren
Schritten von Beschränkungen gekommen
sind die aber nicht nur auf der einen
Seite eine Erschwernis auferlegen
sondern auf der anderen Seite auch Hilfe
und Unterstützung gewähren und ich will
das an zwei Beispielen klar machen wir
haben eine Entscheidung getroffen die
Gastronomie hier mit zwei g plus
deutschlandweit zu belegen das gleiche
gilt ja auch für kulturveranst für
andere Veranstaltungen die nach Hygiene
rahmenkonzepten der Länder laufen und
damit noch Zugang ermöglichen dieses
Zweige Plus ist im Vorfeld in der
Diskussion der letzten Monate immer
wieder auch mit Sorge betrachtet worden
von den gaststättenverbänden aber unter
dem Aspekt dass wir diskutiert haben
dass das Plus das Testen beinhaltet wir
haben hier heute eine Entscheidung
getroffen die das Plus in zwei Bereiche
teilt nämlich einmal mit dem Test und
zum anderen mit der dem Status des
gewusst hatten und das finde ich ist
eine Möglichkeit tatsächlich hier auch
das maßvoll umzusetzen wir bewegen uns
ja überall in Deutschland auf die
Richtung 50% gewusst hätte das bedeutet
die Hälfte der Bevölkerung wird in sehr
absehbarer Zeit in wenigen Tagen
gebustert sein wird dann also ohne Test
auch die Gastronomie Kultur Buchhaltung
anderer Orte die mit der zwei g plus
Regel belegt sind auch besuchen können
das ist ein zusätzlicher Anreiz für das
Boostern das ist ein gewünschter Anreiz
den wir ganz klar auch wollen denn es
ist einfach ja auch erwiesen dass
diejenigen die gebustert sind sollten
Sie dennoch erkranken deutlich mildere
Krankheitsverläufe haben und deswegen
muss unser Ziel sein sowohl die
Impfquote insgesamt bei den ersten
zweitimpfungen aber auch die
boosterquote hoch zu bringen ich kann
Ihnen für Berlin sagen dass wir da auch
noch mal jetzt zusätzlichen Schub
reinbringen durch eine Verstärkung der
Impfkampagne in drei Feldern das erste
Feld ist das Thema kritische
Infrastruktur mit besonderen im Straßen
in den Impfzentren für Polizei für
Feuerwehr für
wasserwerksmitarbeiter zum Beispiel
dieses ist ein wichtiges Feld dass wir
da unsere kritische Infrastruktur
schützen allein dadurch dass wir Sie mit
einem sehr weitgehenden und fl
entdeckenden Impfschutz auch versehen
der zweite Bereich ist und da sehen wir
die Erfolge die wir beim kinderimpfen
auch verzeichnen konnten dass wir auf
das familienimpfen Ausweiten dass wir
also ganz klar sagen nicht nur die
Kinder sondern die Eltern werden gleich
mitgeimpft das hat guten Anklang
gefunden Berlin ist mittlerweile auf
Platz eins beim kinderimpfen und ich
glaube dass wir wenn wir das zusammen
denken mit den Familien mit Angeboten
vor Ort wir da auch noch mal eine große
Chance haben die Quote auch höher zu
bringen und damit verbunden ist der
dritte Bereich der das aufsuchenden
Impfens im Sozialraum in Gebieten wo wir
sehen dass sie im Quote noch nicht so
gut ist und ganz klar auch die
Zusammenarbeit mit Multiplikatoren vor
Ort egal ob das integrationslosen
Stadtteil Mütter andere sind das
aufsuchende impfen im Sozialraum für
Menschen die wir bisher noch nicht
erreichen konnten ist ein wichtiger
Punkt um dieses weitere 30 Millionen
Ziel zu erreichen und natürlich sind wir
alle im länderkreis dazu fest
entschlossen dass wir hier dieses das
bundesweit vorgegebene Ziel auch mit
unseren Anstrengungen in den Ländern
entsprechend erreichen wollen wir haben
uns auch dazu bekannt dass wir und das
ist im Vorfeld immer wieder auch in der
Diskussion gewesen alles dafür tun
wollen die Schulen entsprechend offen zu
halten die Kinderbetreuung auf der einen
Seite zu sichern aber auch eben den
Kinderschutz den Gesundheitsschutz über
die Beschulung über die Angebote zu
gewährleisten das ist auch wichtig um
die Versorgung in der Bevölkerung
aufrecht zu erhalten denn Menschen
brauchen gute Kinderbetreuung damit sie
ihre Arbeit nachgehen können und
deswegen ist es wichtig dass wir hier
den Schulbetrieb auch das stand gar
nicht mehr im Beschluss zur Debatte weil
das eine Selbstverständlichkeit ist dass
wir hier an dieser Stelle eben uns auch
verständigt haben lassen Sie mich noch
zur Impfpflicht sagen wir haben darüber
eine Diskussion gehabt einerseits das
Bekenntnis aller 16 Bundesländer zu
einer allgemeinen Impfpflicht aber
anderer weiß auch die Anerkenntnis der
Tatsache dass das jetzt im Deutschen
Bundestag liegt dass es noch im Januar
ja eine orientierungsdebatte dazu geben
wird und dass dann das
Gesetzgebungsverfahren im Deutschen
Bundestag auch einsetzt das braucht die
Zeit für die notwendigen demokratischen
Prozesse und dieser Zeitplan der ja in
naher Zukunft auch vorgelegt wird muss
eben auch würdigen dass dieser Prozess
für dieses ja doch sehr gravierende
Thema auch eine
gesetzgebungszeit einfach auch benötigt
um dann in Kraft zu treten für über 80
Millionen Menschen wir haben darüber
hinaus und das ist mir sehr wichtig weil
das auch eine Initiative aus Berlin war
im Bereich der Wirtschaftshilfen noch
mal einen zusätzlichen Punkt setzen
können das glaube ich ist sehr wichtig
wenn wir auf der einen Seite zusätzliche
Beschränkungen auferlegen oder
zusätzliche ja Regeln und Kontroll
Notwendigkeiten da muss auf der anderen
Seite auch das Signal ausgehen dass es
Unterstützung gibt und dieses Signal
geht heute an die Wirtschaft die neue
Überbrückungshilfe 4 wird entsprechend
auch noch mal angepasst und das ist mir
sehr wichtig das haben wir immer wieder
gehört vom Einzelhandel auch von der
Gastronomie wenn zusätzliche Kontrollen
jetzt notwendig sind um diese Regeln
einzuhalten dann bedeutet das für die
einzelnen Betriebe für die einzelnen
Wirtschaftsunternehmen einen Aufwand was
Personal was Sachkosten angeht und ich
begrüße es sehr dass hier auch die
Initiative die auch durch Berlin mit
eingebracht worden ist das eben diese
Fixkosten bei den
entsprechenden Überbrückungshilfen was
Sache und Personalkosten angeht
berücksichtigt werden das ist da eine
Zusage vom Bund gibt und außerdem haben
wir uns auch sehr gefreut und begrüßen
das dass der
antragsstaat der Überbrückungshilfe und
auch die
auszahlungsmöglichkeit von
Abschlagszahlungen heute hier als Signal
die Länder durch den Bund gegeben wurde
und natürlich werden wir jetzt von
Länderseite alles dafür tun dass diese
Maßnahmen zügig umgesetzt werden und
dass wir auch Maßnahmen ergreifen um
eventuell Missbrauch entgegenzuwirken
aber denen die es brauchen denen die das
Anrecht darauf haben auch zügig diese
Hilfen zukommen zu lassen soweit von
meiner Seite
vielen Dank dann habe ich schon eine
ganze Reihe von Fragen ich fange an mit
Moritz Rödler und danach Michael Fischer
vielen Dank Herr Bundeskanzler haben mir
scheint die Regelung des frei testen
durch Schnelltests relativ riskant wir
wissen ja dass die Schnelltest die auf
dem Markt sind die omikon Variante
schlechter erkennen als noch andere
Varianten und das gilt grundsätzlich ja
auch für die zertifizierten Tests warum
geht man nicht auf Nummer sicher und
sagt freie testen nur mit PCR-Test
das ist ja sorgfältig mit allen
ExpertInnen Experten diskutiert worden
die
Regelung ist aber von allen dann auch
für die geeignete und am einfachsten
umsetzbare gehalten worden und wir
glauben dass diese Schnelltests auch
eine ausreichende Sicherheit bieten
herr Fischer
Herr Bundeskanzler Ministerpräsident
wüst hat gerade noch mal ein konkreten
Fahrplan für die Einführung der
allgemeinen Impfpflicht von der
Bundesregierung gefordert sie selbst
haben im vergangenen Jahr Anfang Februar
oder Anfang März als Ihre Wunschtermine
für einen Kraft treten genannt im Moment
sieht es ja nicht danach aus dass der
Bundestag zügig also noch im Januar
entscheiden wird deswegen meine Frage
glauben sie dass spätestens Anfang März
noch zu halten sein wird für das
Inkrafttreten der
allgemeinen Impfpflicht werden sie einen
konkreten Fahrplan
vorlegen und werden Sie sich in den
nächsten Wochen auch stärker aktiv in
die Debatte Einschalten aus der
Opposition wird Ihnen ja auch
vorgeworfen an dieser Stelle zu wenig
Führung zu zeigen
ach ich habe ja dafür gesorgt dass wir
in Deutschland jetzt über eine
allgemeine Impfpflicht diskutieren und
das ist das ein Konsens geworden ist ich
bin sehr froh dass ich und die
Regierungschefin und Regierungschefs der
Länder einig sind dass das ein guter und
notwendiger Schritt ist und jetzt liegt
der Beratung im Deutschen Bundestag ich
bin Mitglied des Deutschen Bundestages
werde für eine solche Impfpflicht
Stimmen und auch für sie werden und im
übrigen ist es so dass ich davon ausgehe
dass wenn die Gremien des Deutschen
Bundestages jetzt wieder zusammentreten
zum Jahresanfang auch der Zeitplan
definiert wird in dem die Beratung
stattfinden das ist bei einem so
weitreichenden Eingriff glaube ich eine
angemessene Vorgehensweise und ich habe
großes Vertrauen darin dass die
Abgeordneten eine kluge Weise und auch
aus meiner Perspektive richtige
Entscheidung treffen werden
dann als nächstes Kristina Dunz und im
Anschluss Andreas Kühnast
das Kanzler wir saßen hier schon vor
einem Jahr und hatten dann mit der Delta
Variante zu tun jetzt haben wir mit der
umikon Variante zu tun
vor einem Jahr ist nicht wirklich klare
Kante gezeigt wurden jetzt wieder nicht
wie wollen sie den Menschen die Sorge
nehmen dass wir zwei 23 mit einer
anderen Variante zu tun haben und an
Herrn wüst und Frau Giffey der
Bundeskanzler hat immer wieder betont
die Gesellschaft sei nicht gespalten
darüber kann man streiten relativ
deutlich ist wie gespalten die
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz zumindest
heute war indem sie doch mit sehr
unterschiedlichen Forderungen in das
Treffen mit dem Bundeskanzler gegangen
sind wie wollen sie in einem Wahljahr
mit vier Landtagswahlen der Gesellschaft
Vorleben den Menschen vorleben dass auch
die Politik geeint ist um Corona zu
überwinden
schönen Dank für Ihre Frage zunächst mal
wir sind sehr konsequent der
entscheidungsfroh und das hat auch
Konsequenzen gehabt im realen geschehen
wenn Sie die Entwicklung in Deutschland
vergleichen mit unseren Nachbarländern
dann sehen sie erstens dass wir die
weitreichendsten kontaktbeschränkungen
im größeren Vergleich festgelegt haben
es gibt an der ein oder anderen Stelle
weitergehende aber insgesamt waren wir
diejenigen die schnell und zügig solche
Beschränkungen festgesetzt haben und die
das jetzt ja auch weiter tun auf die
haben wir uns übrigens sehr
einvernehmlich verständigt das heißt das
Papier dass sie heute sehen ist eines
das sehr sorgfältig zwischen den Tagen
und Anfang des Jahres entstanden ist und
der Beteiligung aller die da
Verantwortung tragen und darum hat es
heute auch eine kurze und zügige
Beratung gegeben es gibt also Einigkeit
in der deutschen Politik über das was
als nächstes zu tun ist und ich glaube
das ist auch eines der Geheimnisse dafür
dass wir diesen Schritt so gehen konnten
und das wird auch in der Zukunft so sein
im übrigen haben wir in Deutschland eine
zweite klare Konsequenz gezogen nämlich
dass wir sehr früh damit angefangen
haben zu Boostern
und auch sehr weit fortgeschritten sind
meines Erachtens sind wir unverändert in
Europa wohl das Land mit dem größten
Fortschritt beim Boostern in der
Europäischen Union und das soll auch so
bleiben indem wir das mit großen Tempo
jetzt fortsetzen und beides zusammen die
kontaktbeschränkung die wir ergriffen
haben und im übrigen
das was wir jetzt machen im Blick auf
impfen und Boostern werden wir an
gemeinsamen Weg beschreiten diese Krise
zu bewältigen darauf können sich alle
verlassen also meine Analyse ist wir
handeln gemeinsam und das ist auch
unsere Verpflichtung die wir gegenüber
den Bürgern und Bürgern haben
vielen Dank auch von mir für Ihre Frage
wenn man unterstellt das mit dem Wort
Spaltung der Gesellschaft gemeint ist in
zwei gleich große Teile dann bin ich
ganz beim Bundeskanzler und sehe das
genau wie er dass wir das nicht haben
wir haben eine ganz ganz große Mehrheit
von Menschen die diese Pandemie auch mit
ihren eigenen Beiträgen so schnell wie
möglich hinter sich und hinter uns allen
lassen möchte die dafür Einschränkungen
kaufen nämlich ein Regeln halten die
sich impfen lassen die sich Boostern
lassen die sich zweimal geimpft haben
dreimal die sieht ja danach viertes Mal
werden impfen lassen wir haben eine
Minderheit die das alles ablehnen und
ich finde unsere Aufgabe ist dafür zu
sorgen dass die ganz ganz große Mehrheit
nicht immer wieder hinnehmen muss einen
Wechsel von Lockerungen und Lockdown und
immer wieder währenden
freiheitseinschränkungen das mal wenn
ich das sagen darf das war nur ihre
Einleitung sie kriegen ja auf eine
andere Spaltung hinaus wir haben sehr
sehr viel Einigkeit in der
pandemiebekämpfung zwischen Bund und
Ländern auch heute das ist wichtig denn
die ein Zeit auch das konsistente
umsetzen und gemeinsame vortragen ist am
Ende Erfolgsrezept in unserem föderalen
Land das sind wir auch als
mpk-vorsitzender wichtig Beiträge zu
leisten dass das ein möglichst vielen
Themen gelingt wie es in den letzten
Sitzungen ja auch auf der Fall gewesen
ist es gibt an der ein oder anderen
Stelle ein Lizenz mir persönlich ist
sehr wichtig Versuch zu machen sehr
vorausschauend zu agieren die Lehren zu
ziehen aus dem was wir jetzt in zwei
Jahren Pandemie erlebt haben wir sind an
der Schwelle zum dritten Pandemie ja sie
haben es richtig beschrieben wir wollen
nicht an der Stelle zum vierten Pandemie
ja wieder die gleichen Probleme haben
deswegen haben wir heute darüber
diskutiert welche Konsequenz man aus dem
Appell des expertenrats sich darauf
vorzubereiten sehr schnell in den
nächsten Wochen agieren zu müssen unter
Umständen man daraus zieht das ist aber
in einer solchen Situation in der wir
gerade stehen in der manches ungewiss
ist auch nicht völlig überraschend und
auch normal und dann ist es gut dass wir
das so tun wie wir es hier heute getan
haben aber an vielen anderen Punkten
eben Einigkeit haben diese große
Einigkeit hält auch den Lizenz an der
ein oder anderen Frage aus
ja ich kann dazu ergänzen kann meinem
Kollegen Herrn wüst nur zustimmen
natürlich ist es so dass wenn man eine
schwierige politische und
gesellschaftliche Frage zu bewältigen
hat dass auch mit
intensiven Diskussionen um einen guten
Weg verbunden ist aber ich kann Ihnen
sagen am Ende sitzen wir drei hier und
haben einen gemeinsamen Weg innerhalb
sehr kurzer Zeit verabredet hinter dem
wir auch stehen können und den wir auch
in unsere Länder tragen und wo wir
darauf hinwirken werden dass die
Umsetzung zügig passiert wir werden alle
in den nächsten Tagen die entsprechenden
notwendigen Kabinetts und
parlamentsbefassungen haben um diese
Maßnahmen so zügig es geht umzusetzen
und auch vor allen Dingen gut und
verständlich an unsere Bevölkerung zu
kommunizieren denn das ist ja ganz
entscheidend das war auch bei den
Quarantäne Regeln die jetzt getroffen
worden sind ein ganz handlungsleitender
Punkt das alles was wir hier tun
verständlich und nachvollziehbar sein
muss und die sieben Tage Regelung mit
eben der die entsprechenden Möglichkeit
der freitestung für alle in der
entsprechenden Übersicht die Sie jetzt
hier bekommen haben das ist deine klare
einheitliche Regelung zu der wir uns
alle verständigt haben das ist bei der
Komplexität der Lage schon eine große
Leistung und insofern würde ich gerne
wirklich sehen wollen was hier heute an
Einigkeit geschafft worden ist in einer
sehr kurzen sehr konstruktiven Sitzung
und natürlich zu den Punkten über die
wir Diskussionsbedarf haben werden wir
auch weiter sprechen und wir haben ja
auch verständigt dass wir uns im Januar
auch hier wieder zusammenfinden um dann
auch wieder zu bewerten wie sind die
Maßnahmen wie ist die Wirkung und daraus
dann Schlüsse für die weitere Arbeit zu
ziehen aber ich finde wir sollten jetzt
nicht eine Spaltung herbeirreden die so
einfach nicht da sondern es gibt eine
konstruktive Zusammenarbeit und das
Abwägen und diskutieren über den besten
Weg
falls Sie noch nicht so weit
fortgeschritten sind beim Lesen des
Textes wir treffen uns wieder am 24
Januar
als nächstes Andreas Künast danach
Andreas kühners vom ZDF und danach
Andreas Rinke von Reuters
Bundeskanzler sie haben jetzt immer
wieder betont wie wichtig ihnen die
Einigkeit in der deutschen Politik ist
jetzt hat Herr wüst namens der
unionsgeführten Länder ein weiteres Mal
gefordert die epidemische Lage wieder
einzuführen was würde es schaden wenn
Sie den Wunsch erfüllen im Augenblick
ist es so dass alle Dinge die jemand
umsetzen möchte und auf die wir uns hier
verständigt haben von dem gegenwärtigen
Gesetzen umgesetzt werden können
Herr Bundeskanzler sie haben eben noch
mal ausdrücklich auch für den moderner
Impfstoff geworben ist das ihrer Meinung
nach ein Grund das mangelnde Vertrauen
von vielen Bürgern offenbar in diesen
Impfstoff warum die Impfkampagne im
Moment etwas lahmt oder haben sie eher
das Gefühl dass die Bundesländer ihre
Aufgaben bei dieser Impfkampagne noch
nicht ausreichend gemacht haben und eine
kurze zweite Frage weil wir bei allen
Varianten erlebt haben dass auch Omegon
jetzt sich wieder zwischen Ländern hin
und her verbreitet sehen Sie auf
EU-Ebene noch einen stärkeren
Abstimmungsbedarf damit das
möglicherweise bei der nächsten Variante
etwas stärker eingedämmt werden kann
wir haben hervorragende Impfstoffe das
gilt für alle die in Deutschland
eingesetzt werden und demnächst kommt ja
noch einer dazu der vielleicht
diejenigen überzeugt die mit den
bisherigen Impfstoffen etwas skeptisch
waren da kann ich nur sagen wer auf den
richtigen Impfstoff gewartet hat jetzt
kann er sich impfen lassen er ist da und
man kann ihn nutzen das ist doch eine
gute Sache und wir haben zwei sehr
moderne Impfstoffe moderner und biontech
von den beiden Unternehmen und die sind
beide hervorragend und ich kann alle nur
dazu auffordern dass sie die
Möglichkeiten die sie haben nutzen
vielleicht darf ich den Satz noch sagen
wer eine Möglichkeit hat sich impfen zu
lassen sollte da nicht hingehen sondern
eher hinrennen das ist jetzt etwas was
in diesem Monat geschehen soll das gilt
fürs impfen das gilt auch für das
Boostern es trägt dazu bei dass man sich
schützt vor den
Gefahren der Infektion und gerade was
die neue virusmutation betrifft was
Omikron betrifft ist völlig klar dass
sogar ein einfacher Impfschutz schon ein
vor vielen Konsequenzen
schützt und das dass man besonders gut
geschützt ist wenn man
dreimal geimpft ist mit der
Auffrischungsimpfung und wenn man dann
zweimal biontech hat und das dritte Mal
moderner kriegt ist das ein ganz
großartiger Weg und es gibt auch welche
die haben erst das Produkt von
astrazenica bekommen dann haben sie
biontech genommen und dann kommt als
drittes moderner und das ist genau gut
und Europa muss zusammenarbeiten in
dieser Frage wir haben das ja auch
miteinander diskutiert beim letzten
Zusammentreffen der
Regierungschefs in Europa im
Europäischen Rat das werden wir auch
weiter tun ich glaube das Bewusstsein
dass man nicht gegeneinander sondern
miteinander die Dinge nur hinbekommen
kann ist gewachsen
als nächstes Michaela küchner von der
Deutschen Welle und danach Daniel
Brüsseler von der SZ
sie haben nicht geimpften empfohlen sie
sollen jetzt zur Impfung Rennen der
französische Präsident hat viel
deutlichere Worte neulich gefunden was
er von nicht impfen hält worauf müssen
sich denn nicht geimpfte in Deutschland
gefasst machen und angesichts der
Brisanz der Lage was ist denn ihre
Haltung zu der Situation in Kasachstan
vor allem dem Schießbefehl und der
Präsenz russischer Truppen dort
das ist jetzt aber eine steile Kurve
aber okay also erstens wer nicht geimpft
ist
gefährdet sich selbst
denn das wissen wir dass diejenigen die
ungeimpft sind eine große Gefahr
laufendes sie von der Infektion erreicht
werden und dadurch dass sich die neue
Variante sogar noch schneller überträgt
wie wir an den Zahlen unserer
Nachbarländer sehen können muss jeder
davon ausgehen und jede die sich nicht
hat impfen lassen dass die Infektion sie
bald erreichen wird und das ist dann für
einige davon ein hohes gesundheitliches
Risiko denn das was man an der ein oder
anderen Stelle hört dass es nicht so
gefährlich sei stimmt nicht die
Infektionsgefahren sind etwas geringer
aber sie sind groß genug und deshalb
müssen wir alles dafür tun dass
möglichst viele sich
schützen indem sie sich impfen lassen
das ist die einzige Antwort die man
darauf vernünftigerweise geben kann
im übrigen ist es so dass wir klare
Positionen haben wir wollen
Rechtsstaatlichkeit überall schützen wir
rufen dazu auf dass es keine Gewalt gibt
und das Gewalt auch unterbleibt und
selbstverständlich gilt das auch dafür
dass es keine Gewalt gegen Bürgern und
Bürger geben sollte also insofern
befinden wir uns da im großen Einklang
mit dem was sie von der Europäischen
Union von der Bundesregierung und von
mir hier hören und von vielen anderen in
der Welt die sagen bitte kommt zurück zu
einer friedlichen Weiterentwicklung im
Land
Rössler und dann im Anschluss
birgitieren von Bloomberg
Herr Bundeskanzler sie haben auf die
Erfolge der bisherigen Maßnahmen
verwiesen sind sie denn überzeugt dass
Deutschland ein rasanter Anstieg wie in
anderen Ländern aufgrund der omikon
Variante erspart bleibt oder fürchten
sie nicht vielleicht auch dass diese
Entwicklung nur einfach ein bisschen
später eintritt und zur Frage nach der
epidemischen Lage haben sie gesagt im
Augenblick könnten alle Maßnahmen
getroffen werden die zu treffen sein
können Sie das auch für die Zukunft
garantieren und können Sie auch
garantieren dass dann eben auch in der
ausreichenden Geschwindigkeit diese
Maßnahmen getroffen werden vielen Dank
zur zweiten Frage zuerst ja es wird
immer schnell entschlossen gehandelt
werden und es wird auch immer schnell
und entschlossen gehandelt werden können
alles was notwendig ist wird gemacht und
es wird keinen Zeitverzug in diesen
Angelegenheiten geben
und dass wir konsequent handeln können
haben wir nun gerade gezeigt sie haben
mit ihrer ersten Frage ja darauf
hingewiesen dass das Infektionsgeschehen
in Deutschland sich im Augenblick nicht
ganz so dramatisch entwickelt hat wie in
den Nachbarländern und das ist eindeutig
auch darauf zurückzuführen dass wir so
konsequente schnelle zügige und
entschlossene Maßnahmen ergriffen haben
und deshalb ist auch richtig dass die
gemeinsame Beschlüsse die wir heute
fassen weiter schnell zügig und
entschlossen sind und zum Beispiel mit
der weiteren Festlegung das jetzt in
allen Restaurants in Kneipen in Bars
überall
2g+ gilt und das nur geboote von dem
Testen befreit sind gehen wir ja diesen
einen weiteren Schritt das ist doch sehr
weitreichend wenn man das in das gesamte
Setting der Maßnahmen einreibt die wir
bereits ergriffen haben
nein
ich kann nicht ausschließen dass es
nicht zu einem erheblichen Anstieg der
Infektionen in der nächsten Zeit kommt
wir gehen eher davon aus dass es zu
einem Anstieg kommt wie groß er sein
wird das können wir nicht vorhersagen
weil wir ja auch so viele Maßnahmen
ergriffen haben und die ihre Wirkung
haben das Boostern das Impfen die ganzen
kontaktbeschränkungen die wir gemacht
haben wie wir jetzt sehen und jetzt ist
es eine Rechnung mit unglaublich vielen
Variablen wie sehr sich der schnelle
Fortschritt beim Boostern auswirkt wie
sehr sich der Fortschritt bei der
Impfkampagne auswirkt wie massiv die
Auswirkungen sind von unseren
weitreichenden kontaktbeschränkungen die
wir insbesondere für ungeimpfte haben
und die wir jetzt ja noch mal verschärft
haben im Hinblick zum Beispiel auf die
2g+ Regelung für Restaurants
das kann keiner vorhersagen aber wir
sollten davon ausgehen dass es doch zu
hören Infektionszahlen kommt und zwar
auch zu solchen die
viel zu groß sind im Hinblick auf das
was wir gerne sehen wollen also deshalb
haben wir ja diese Entscheidung heute
getroffen und deshalb noch mal der
Aufruf lasst euch impfen lasst euch
Boostern das hilft
von Bloomberg und dann noch Melanie
Ammann vom Spiegel ja ich möchte direkt
daran anschließen also die die
Entwicklung ist ja recht dynamisch im
Moment und am 24 wollen sie sich dann
erneut zusammensetzen was ist denn das
Kriterium dafür dass dann eventuell dann
auch noch weitere Maßnahmen ergriffen
werden oder eben mit dass man davon
absieht geht es dann in Richtung der der
Booster Impfungen oder auch Mustern
letztendlich die ihr das
Infektionsgeschehen rückläufig sein ich
bin sehr froh dass wir zum Beispiel das
Experten reden um haben dass wir die
guten Beratungen durch das RKI haben
dass wir uns alle miteinander ständig
besprechen denn das müssen Sie schon so
vorstellen dass hier ständig Kontakte
stattfinden die Ministerpräsidenten das
gibt Zusammentreffen des Bundeskanzlers
mit den regierungschefinnen
Regierungschefs der Länder heute war ja
nur praktisch die Beurkundung eines ganz
intensiven diskussions- und
konsens-prozesses indem wir auch die
Probleme und die Herausforderung
sorgfältig be gesprochen haben und so
muss das aus meiner Sicht auch sein so
wird es in der nächsten Zeit auch sein
wir werden die Lage ganz genau
beobachten und wenn etwas zu tun ist
wird sofort gehandelt darauf können sich
alle verlassen da wird es nichts geben
was wir nicht tun weil wir irgendwie
es aufschieben weil wir
da Zweifel haben ob man das sich trauen
sollte doch das wird dann gemacht werden
aber was dann notwendig ist das kann
keiner richtig vorhersagen deshalb
müssen wir das genau betrachten ich habe
eben die vielen Variablen gesagt und das
sind nur einige die Einfluss haben auf
die reale Entwicklung des
infektionsgeschehens wir wissen dass wir
das was man heute sagen kann dass es
richtig ist alles unternommen haben das
ist sehr sehr viel
aber wir können erst wenn wir die
Entwicklung weitersehen gucken welche
Maßnahmen dann zielgerichtet notwendig
sind die werden wir aber ergreifen
dann habe ich Melanie Ammann und dann
als allerletzten noch einmal kurz Moritz
ja Bundeskanzlei ich wollte noch einen
Frage zur Impfpflicht Stellen der
ursprüngliche Zeitplan den sie ja jetzt
so wenn ich Ihre Antwort richtig
verstanden habe ein bisschen kassiert
haben der wurde ja von ihnen gesetzt
Ende Februar Anfang März können wir die
Impfpflicht haben haben sie ja im
Interview gesagt im ZDF jetzt scheint
das nicht mehr zu gelten man hat den
Eindruck jetzt soll das Thema auf die
lange Bank geschoben werden vielleicht
gar nicht mehr kommen auch auf Wunsch
ihres Koalitionspartners FDP können Sie
heute noch mal hier sagen die
Impfpflicht wird kommen oder wird sie
nicht kommen und wenn ja was ist der
neue Zeithorizont
schönen Dank für Ihre Frage ich habe die
ganze Zeit gesagt dass ich für eine
Impfpflicht bin und ich bleibe dabei das
habe ich heute noch mal begründet aber
auch schon bei jedem anderen Gelegenheit
wo ich danach gefragt worden bin ich
habe mich von vornherein darauf
festgelegt dass ich finde dass dies ein
Prozess sei sollte den der Deutsche
Bundestag mit einer
abgeordnetentscheidung jenseits des
fraktionszwangs trifft ich glaube ich
ist der Bedeutung dieses Themas dass ihr
jeden einzeln mit seinem eigenen Körper
berührt auch angemessen aber es muss
schnell gehen und das wird es auch und
davon bin ich sehr überzeugt also ich
setze mich aktiv dafür ein dass es dazu
kommt
und der Deutsche Bundestag tritt jetzt
zusammen und dann gibt es dort die
zuständigen Gremien in denen sich die
Abgeordnete darüber verständigen wie sie
ihre Zeitpläne festlegen und dann werden
wir auch hören wie das geschieht aber
alles was ich wahrnehme ist das dort
auch alle das schnell voranbringen
wollen
dann als allerletzter Moritz Rödler
vielen Dank dass ich noch eine zweite
Frage stellen darf an Herrn wüst der
Ministerpräsident sie haben eben noch
mal darauf hingewiesen dass sie so gut
finden dass es eine Einigkeit
grundsätzlich gibt in dieser Runde jetzt
hat ihr cdu-parteikollege Haseloff
Ministerpräsident von Sachsen-Anhalt
gerade eben erklärt 2g+ in der Gastro
wäre das in Sachsen-Anhalt erstmal nicht
geben was bringen denn dann solche
einigkeitsappelle und solche runden hier
wo wir stundenlang zusammen sitzen wenn
dann doch jeder macht was er denkt
glaube wenn Sie die genaue Gründung des
Kollegen haselhoffs abwarten dann werden
sie den Verweis auf neue
Rechtsgrundlagen
sehen die in wenigen Tagen durch
Bundesrat durch den Bundestag erst und
dann durch den Bundesrat geschaffen
werden ich glaube darauf bezieht sich
seine Äußerung was die zeitliche
Umsetzung angeht so habe ich jedenfalls
auch seinen Beitrag im Laufe der
heutigen Sitzungen verstanden
dann bedanke ich mich bei allen
Beteiligten dass sie heute am
Freitagnachmittag Freitagabend hier
ausgeharrt haben wünsche Ihnen ein gutes
Wochenende einen heilen Heimweg danke
mich bei den Kolleginnen Kollegen auf
dem Podium und beende die
Pressekonferenz